[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in
60 minutes brought to you by spectator
tv and recorded on thursday the 22nd of
april
i'm fraser nelson editor of the
spectator standing in for
andrew neal so wish me luck on this
week's show we're going to
be looking at joe biden's first hundred
days
we're going to look at the indian
variant of kovitz and finding out how
much more dangerous it is
we'll have a former chancellor sajid
javid on the football super league
debacle and a former swedish prime
minister
carl bilt about what to make about
putin's ambitions in ukraine
all that to come in the next hour and as
ever a very special thanks to charles
stanley for their support
of this program charles stanley is one
of the uk's leading wealth management
firms
and one of the oldest companies on the
london stock exchange we're delighted
to be partnering with charles stanley
now first it's
always been a hundred days since donald
trump left his
office we've had to learn to live
without his twitter feed and his various
verbal bonds but
has joe biden been doing much better
freddie gray writes the cover piece on
that this week and joins me now as does
kate andrews our economics correspondent
so freddie let's look at the biden
scorecard
where does it leave us so far well the
scorecard
i mean is is probably quite positive if
you're a
biden supporter if you're a democrat
the vaccine rollout is he's accelerated
it it's been a big success
uh the covid relief package has made
people happy giving people money
uh always makes them quite keen on you
as i'm sure kate will go on to explain
but there's also been this of
undercurrent of concern about
biden and um you talked about
trump's ability to inability to stop
himself talking i think biden has that
problem
and i think we saw it this week with the
derek chovin trial where
before the jury had announced its
verdict biden weighed in and said i hope
it's the right verdict and i think the
evidence is overwhelming
there was really no need for him to do
that and it was very strange
that he felt this urge to to weigh in
because nobody was expecting the
president to
to sort of weigh in on what was a very
tense and explosive racially charged
moment
right he's also called xi jinping a thug
he's called vladimir putin a
killer these are words that could have
come straight from donald trump's
twitter account
well yes i mean the the difference i
suppose between him and trump is that
his team are able to keep him hushed up
and they've done a pretty good job of
that i mean he's only done one press
conference
and it went reasonably well but it
wasn't a difficult press conference i
think the wall street journal
were allowed one quite critical question
but apart from that it was really
journalists lobbing him softballs right
now kate sanders
um you are you know quite a conservative
and fiscally and you're also almost a
british
citizen you've completed the long and
winding road down to you're indefinitely
to remain so congratulations
on that but you still open the mail to
receive a massive check
from from joe biden
yeah i did i've opened a few checks now
from america
one had donald trump's name at the
bottom and i thought it might be fake it
kind of looked
like monopoly money and but then i got a
second check
for one thousand four hundred dollars uh
which is the stimulus the most recent
stimulus and i thought oh my gosh
something has gone
terribly wrong and how can it be the
case that the u.s treasury is trying to
boost the economy in south london
sending me these checks when they were
originally designed for people
who were losing their jobs overnight in
america because america had nothing like
the generous furlough scheme
that exists here in the uk now
thankfully fraser here at the spectator
i was able to keep working throughout
lockdown
but if i hadn't been if i had been
furloughed here in the uk
i would have been taken care of through
the furlough scheme so that money really
isn't
meant for me and i think it poses a lot
of economic questions about
just how much free cash is is just
flowing around in the united states at
the moment
a lot of economists are saying this
should come with inflation warnings we
just don't really know what's going to
happen
this time around um when we've done so
much money printing and it isn't just to
balance
the books it isn't just to give banks
reserves it's actually going in to the
real economy into people's bank accounts
but it presents i think ethical
questions as well
what exactly do i do with this money and
i i really think a lot of people out
there
and in america needed it more than i do
at the moment it's pinned to my fringe
and uh my fridge and i'm really torn
about what i'm gonna do
right but i put it to you kate that
people like you've been warning about
governments borrowing too much
printing too much money for a long long
time the world hasn't fallen apart in
fact
it seems that america is going to do
even better than china when it comes to
recovering from the pandemic so maybe
biden
is on to something and people who worry
about debt levels
are i've got their their mindset in an
era where this caused far worse
ramifications than it does
now because we're now into the era of
modern monetary theory
well i'm not an economist and i'm not
necessarily warning i'm i'm reporting on
those who do
i think a lot of people would say that
there has been inflation
since 2008 when kiwi really took off and
it's been an asset crisis the rich
got a lot richer the cost of homes and
assets
skyrocketed but you're right fraser we
didn't see inflation in the usual way
and so people are saying now well why
would it be different now there are a
lot of reasons you could say it's going
to be different
and you could look at the world's
economy and say that china
thriving and and producing its goods
sending its goods out into the world
economy labor forces emerging all over
the world
that's going to be difficult to repeat a
second time round and you could
look um as as i was saying to those
asset prices and you could say well
maybe it will just do that this time
round it um it won't be different there
are a lot of good questions to be asking
but the truth is that the chancellor
here in the uk is
very worried about this his budget in
march was designed
to make the uk's finances biden proof
so to speak he is worried that if there
is any uptick
in interest rates in inflation that
the uk could be in a really difficult
position to pay its bills
um so it's something that really hasn't
been spoken about for a long time
because as you say there was this
this new theory that everything was
going to be fine you could print as much
spend as much as you want there would be
no consequences but
in recent months a lot of big hitters
and the chancellor
and economists around the world have
been asking these questions because they
can sense that something
isn't quite right that at some point and
we are going to have to address
the trillions and trillions of dollars
and here in the uk
many hundreds of billions of pounds and
that have been spent in such a short
period of time
now freddie you say in your cover piece
that biden is
creating a middleway between the old
center and the new left
from what kate is saying if he's
spending all of his money then you left
ought to be quite pleased with him
so far so how is that that coalition
going
well i don't think it works i think in
the piece i said it's a bit like an
abusive relationship between biden and
the radical left
he keeps saying things that they want to
hear you know that he's going to
uh you know he'll he'll push for
critical race theory in schools for
instance his administration will do that
and then the radical left you know the
alexander occasional cortes of this
world
uh just say it's not enough it's not
enough and biden keeps saying i know
it's not enough you know we're going to
do more we're on this journey towards
um effectively a a sort of quite radical
utopia in america
um and and they're not satisfied so he
yeah i mean at the moment it's working
because he's throwing a lot of money at
things
um it's the early days of the presidency
but he's not winning over the radical
left in any meaningful way
and kate you voted for him because you
wanted a unifier you wanted somebody to
dial down the tone of american politics
have you got in that respect what you
voted for
something closer to it i think joe biden
and
still makes the case for unity far
stronger than donald trump ever did
i would completely concede though that
biden has benefited from
much of trump's very harsh rhetoric that
he didn't have to tone it down too much
to still be seen as the better
alternative fraser you mentioned some of
the language he's been using about
world leaders and some of his actions as
well i mean we've been
so laser focused on the eu threatening
to ban the exports of vaccines that
other countries have bought through
private companies well the us has done
just that canada i think about the
highest number of doses per resident
in the entire world and they can't get
their hands on these vaccines because
the u.s
won't send them it's a very
america-first policy
but because trump took that to the
extreme and joe biden doesn't use that
exact language he just about
gets away with it so you know do i do i
think he's perfect by absolutely
no means that said you know it's
difficult to fault in many ways
domestically
the vaccine rollout i believe the us has
now hit
200 million doses in a hundred days of
the biden
presidency now in normal times you would
have some bipartisan support for this
donald trump clearly laid that
groundwork and and put the
u.s in a position that we'll be able to
manufacture these vaccines and roll them
out joe biden is actually doing it
in the good old days you might have both
of these men doing a joint video or a
joint campaign to encourage people
to get vaccinated obviously not the case
now
um but biden you know if the only thing
he did in his presidency was get the u.s
vaccinated i think that would be
a huge success and the last thing to
remember is that the money that he's
spending and the work that he's doing
like it or loathe it from his
perspective he thinks he has two years
to do it
because the midterms are creeping up
they're soon they're next year
and he doesn't know whether or not his
party will get to hold congress
or if the republicans might take back
the senate they could hold it the
republican party
is you know crumbled on the floor right
now but it's very very close already so
from his perspective
he needs to do everything in his
presidency of four years
actually in two years just in case the
republicans come back and that makes his
life a lot harder to to get policies
over the line
now freddie barack obama used the
language of unity very much in his
presidency although he turned out to be
a very divisive president perhaps
creating the conditions that led to
donald trump
in the first place how is biden doing so
far in that respect
and how how are the rights in other
words and behaving towards them do they
feel this wage do they feel listens to
the trump voters who let's face it are
half of america
um feel that biden is doing what he can
to understand
their concerns or are they itching to
get back at them with somebody
perhaps even more incendiary than trump
well i don't think i think you know a
lot of the alienated classes of america
feel uh alienated and there's not a lot
biden has done
to address that i do think as the
midterms approach
uh he may try to become more of a
centrist figure
but is that what uh alienated america is
looking for that's that's the difficult
conundrum he has to answer
i don't think we've seen any sign that
he has any good answers for that
question
freddie and kate thanks very much for
joining me now meanwhile
on the home front it's been a pretty
busy week and katie bowles our deputy
political editor joins me now
katie let's start with the dyson episode
we've seen texts from the prime minister
sent to the
entrepreneur james dyson servicing
basically promising him tax cuts if he
makes
ventilators on time how damaging
is this well we know labour want to
ultimately run a campaign against tory
sleeves in the idea that it will slowly
if not immediately damage the tory brand
and i think they see it as a slow build
exercise
i think where does james dyson fit into
that if we're looking at
the text messages over ventilators
i think there's a sense that you were
talking about doing things in the
treasury in an
unofficial manner i'm not personally
sure how damaging this is i think a lot
of people just think
back to the peak of the crisis when i
think we can all remember that
there was a huge concern in the country
that there weren't enough ventilators
and
it was almost an all hands on deck i
think that when it comes to the
various uh allegations labour is looking
into
is the things outside of that emergency
period which have the um
the most potential to hurt the
government in terms of tourist lease
but it's been a busy week politically
and the government seemed to have used
especially the football scandal as a
good time to bury some bad news that
there's no longer going to be
a on camera televised briefing and
allegra stratton is no longer going to
be
the faith of boris johnson's government
as was originally the plan
yes so this is news we've had this week
and i think to many it doesn't feel
as a huge surprise they've been
constantly pushed back
since allegra stratton's appointed into
the role six months ago
um and pushed further and further back
most recently we're told they'd be in
may after the local elections and now
uh they're not going to happen at all um
why is this i think we need to remember
that her appointment was very
controversial at the time within downing
street
um it led to ultimately civil war
breaking out
you had the comms chief lee kane
resigning from his role
and dominic cummings followed quite soon
after so it really changed the makeup of
number 10.
right and also we had a rather
embarrassing episode sorry
but meanwhile they spent 2 million quid
on this great glitzy briefing room which
is presumably going to be used what now
to store junk
well apparently to have press
conferences uh with ministers
you know on an ad hoc basis but i do
think a lot of people are going to think
that was the best use of taxpayers money
and i suppose when you're trying to work
out well why have these press briefings
been stopped i think it's down to a
number of reasons
i think one of those is if you think
back to the fact that
this was the brainchild of lee kane but
he didn't want allegra stratton to win
the role
um we knew that carrie simmons boris
johnson's fiance was pushing for her to
get the role and it
all became rather messy in the end lee
kane left so we had a situation where
the person who championed the format was
out of the building but we had someone
to
to do the job and i think that the fact
that there were also people in that
building who were quite skeptical about
the
um the pros of press briefings thought
there was a lot of collateral damage
they could do
um meant there was this creep towards i
think a cancellation
we know there had been rehearsals of
press briefings in recent months i don't
think they convinced
the second director of coms james slack
of their merits he's now also left
and we're now into a third director of
communications jack doyle as of last
friday
and it seems one of his first acts a
decisive one was to say no to these
briefings
thanks katie now just to say if you
haven't tried the spectator magazine
before
we're offering a 20 pound amazon voucher
when you take out a trial
subscription for 12 pounds do the maths
and it's
pretty much uneconomical but i don't
make these offers
anyway you can avail yourself by doing
spectator dot
co dot uk forward slash tv offer or just
google spectator tv
and it should come up 12 pounds for
three months of a spectator
and a 20 pound amazon voucher now the
worlds of football and politics collided
spectacularly this week
when england's six largest clubs say
they were going to break away to form a
european
super league they knew there'd be
outrage they thought the government has
no powers to stop them
but the politicians didn't lose much
time in saying they would vote to give
themselves more powers
perhaps the biggest threat came from
sajid javids the former
chancellor and a former banker he fought
to come up with a super tax that would
penalize them and potentially neutralize
any financial advantage to them joining
the super league
sacha javid joins me now now you're a
former banker sachit javid
and i would say one of the most pro-free
markets
mps in the party you've been denouncing
industrial strategies and things like
that but
here you are proposing what is in effect
a punishment tax for companies who do
something the government
doesn't like so can you explain your
thinking and how you reconcile this with
your free market principles
yeah look i think the the thinking
starts with the importance
of football the importance of football
to our country to our society
i think most people would agree the vast
majority that football
is part of the dna of our country you
know we invented the beautiful game we
exported it around the world
it's part of the social fabric of almost
every community
in the uk i remember when i was the
culture secretary
that your football was very much part of
just that part of our culture that's why
it's overseen
by that secretary of state and and i
think that
gives it special meaning as it is much
more than just a sport or just a
business it is really
part of the the fabric of our our
country and so first of all i'd say as a
conservative that someone
who believes in the value of our
institutions in defending them in our
heritage
uh that it's important to to stand up
for those values and i think what was
proposed was challenging
uh that and the other thing is also as a
conservative but especially one that
believes passionately in free enterprise
whether it's low taxes sensible
regulation
i also believe in competition and what
was being proposed was
a cozy cartel of elite clubs there's no
prospect for those founders to
be promoted or relegated no matter how
badly performed
they would still be in that club and i
think that there's not just
anti-competitive
but it also just goes against the sort
of
the sense of british fair play that we
all have everyone just knew it didn't
smell right it wouldn't work and it was
just wrong in every way
right but you're also a former financier
you would have seen the very clear
financial logic for this you'll also
know that the audience for the football
matches is global now it's not just
it's not just a british and so you can
see here the financial rationale for
what they wanted to do this could have
led to
a lot more profit for them a lot more
money for the taxpayer
it could have built a british industry
and even more than it was already isn't
that the sort of thing which you know in
another era conservatives would have
been applauding
um no i don't think so i think how
conservatives have reacted
uh to this is is consistent with uh our
values in including in
in in the past if you look at i think
your previous conservative governments
and and that is because as i said it
goes to the very heart of what we are as
a country our institutions our heritage
but
it is also much more than a business of
course that for the owners
of these clubs yeah i think people can
see what they're motivated by they
weren't exactly trying to hide it which
is
they're not really fans of their own
clubs and stuff they're fans of money
and for them it was about you know how
can they squeeze even more out of what
they just see as a business
a trophy asset how can they squeeze more
and what they would be looking at
i guess more than anything is probably
the spreadsheet the spreadsheet that's
got all their
sort of their their revenues and then
their costs and they're trying to
maximize that profit and that's why for
the government and for anyone that was
interested in
putting an end to these proposals uh it
made sense to
look at how can you change the dynamics
on that spreadsheet how can you
basically splash some more red ink
into that spreadsheet so that they are
deterred from taking the action that
they've set out
well they've now abandoned their plan
but still the government review
is going ahead it looks as if football
might
be regulated in spite of all this even
if they've done what you pretty much
asked them to do so can't we see another
government power grab in action here
no no no not really i wouldn't be
concerned about that i mean first of all
they have you right as you say they have
come to their senses
very quickly and abandoned these plans i
think first
and foremost they've abandoned them
because they've seen the the real
gut reaction of real fans of football
not these owners but they're real fans
you remember
these are people that often they they
they save as much as they can so they
can buy tickets go and support their
club and they believe in the dream and
these guys were trying to kill
that dream and so the fans stopped this
but i also think
what's happened is that the owners heard
what the government had to say
what the prime minister said what oliver
dowden said
and other party leaders as well that
they would take action if they had to
and the government had
ways of taking action you know i
remember when i was home secretary
every police force would i think at some
point contacted me and said look we get
these big bills for policing these big
football matches
and part of the rationale was the
taxpayer picks up some of the expense of
putting on football matches because
there's a commitment to the community
so the government could have changed
that equation for them but i think this
super tax proposal
uh also had a real bite to it because i
think the club owners could see
that the government could if it wanted
to we've got a majority
in fact the even without the despite the
majority
that i think within parliament there's
cross-party support if the government
wanted to take action and amend the
finance bill that's in front of
parliament right now
and and and take that kind of action
with the tax then it would have really
you turn their financial proposals as
they see them
completely upside down and i think the
prospect of that
probably did helped in helping to change
their minds as well
as a former home secretary you were also
in charge of the visa
process uh is it the case the the
the government if it chose to in the
same way that they could choose to
charge these clubs for policing
that would make life more expensive for
them couldn't also
choose to not grant for example visas
for any international players that are
transferred is that
a tool that was then at the government's
disposal that could
have conceivably been used had this
scheme went ahead
that's another example of a potential a
tool that could have been
used and now that we're outside the eu
we have even more sort of
control of who comes in and out of our
uh country
but i think what this shows is that for
the reasons
uh i hope that i've set out and i think
the the vast majority of mps not just
because set of mps have really shared
is that this is much more than just
about sport or
business this goes to the very heart of
the kind of country that we are
we could see the public reaction the
strength of that reaction
and it's the government's job to to
respond to that it fits in
very much with conservative values
whether that's on heritage and
institutions or promoting competition
and uh and all those tools that we've
talked about
yeah over the last few minutes i think
they're all available whether it's visas
it's the prospect of a different type of
regulation
and ultimately a taxation right these
are three
new tools that didn't exist or don't
exist now they could have been conjured
up you
say but we often quite hear a government
ringing their hands thinking what can we
do about
for example the tech giants who don't
pay enough tax tax the
amazons of this world haven't you just
found the answer to that question if you
want to you can
invent tools that can change the
behavior of bring private companies so
couldn't you apply this
to other big corporations who you don't
think are playing by the rules and are
not contributing
to the social cohesion in a way that you
describe with football clubs
i think that there is a big difference
and that is that
ordinarily in normal circumstances there
are structures
in place that would deal with
let's say your companies enterprises
that are that are
acting in some kind of unfair way let's
say on on taxation
if we feel that if the government feels
people feel that they're not paying
let's say their fair share of tax so
you've given a really good example which
is the
the tech industry the tech giants and
there are procedures
in in place already institutions to help
deal with that so
for example just taking that the tech
companies
the government has responded to that in
an orderly way by
introducing a digital services tax we've
done that as a country unilaterally
the government also knows that it
requires an international solution we
can't do everything on our own
so through the oecd through the g7 g20
there's discussions
that are going on which are actually for
what i hear heading
all in the right direction so that is
something that the government can react
to through sort of usual
procedures that are already in existence
and put in place in a let's say a more
orderly way and that's what happens and
also if i may say when it comes to
competition as well
you know in most parts of uh if you
if you think of just businesses for most
businesses and as i say football is much
more than a business but the owners
think of it as a business so from that
perspective
for most parts of the economy there are
either existing regulators in place uh
the utility regulators for example
but and there's also overarching
regulators such as the competition
authority i think the the difference
here was that it wasn't
clear that because it's more than just a
business it wasn't clear
whether those existing structures would
actually do the job and i think that's
why the government was right
to say that if we need to go beyond that
we will
well and exactly and you wonder if this
is going to be the last time the
governments do this because right now
they've made clear but they are
willing to give themselves any powers to
regulate any companies and that will be
the the question whether we might be
entering a less liberal
more interventionist period of of
government but before you go one final
question this whole scheme was going to
be
um bankrolled by jp morgan to the tune
of something like five billion dollars
yet you are an advisor to jp morgan you
just
played a pretty big role in scuppering
this um this whole scheme it's not going
to make things a bit awkward at your
next
jp morgan meeting no not at all
uh my my uh advisory work with jake
morgan is about talking about the global
economy the pandemic
global geopolitics it's got nothing to
do with
actual transactions and uh and
i can say what i like when i like and
that's what matters what the only job
that
really matters at the end of the day is
my job as an mp and looking after my
constituents and doing my best for this
country
sergio javid thanks very much for
joining us on spectator tv
now the prime minister has had something
else on his mind this week it's his
twice cancelled trip
to india covet levels there are getting
pretty serious
registered the biggest spike in the
world recently
and he figured perhaps understandably
now is not the best time for a trip
but how much of this is down to the new
variant strain of covet
that's been discovered over there i'm
joined by somebody who can distill the
facts from the panic
dr jeffrey barrett directs the covet 19
genomics initiative
at the welcome sanger institute in
cambridge and he joins me now
dr barrett welcome to spectator tv now
we've heard a lot about the indian
variants but
what do we know about it and to what
extent is it overwhelming
india in the same way that the kent
variants changed the narrative here
in britain and on the continent yeah
the short answer is i don't think we
know yet
there is some evidence that this new
variant dubbed b1617
has been growing in frequency in india
at the same time
as the recent tragic surge but that can
sometimes happen
uh by coincidence and it doesn't
necessarily prove on its own
that the new variant is in fact driving
that surge
the way we tried to unpick that problem
in the case of the kent variant back in
december last year
was we could watch because we do quite a
lot of what we call genomic surveillance
in the uk where we sequence the genome
of the virus to really
carefully track each variant from place
to place
and what we saw there was that every
time the b117 or kent variant would
arrive in a new place in the uk
it would very rapidly completely take
over and we've seen the same thing
happen in other countries in the month
since then
so that takes quite a lot of data to
build a sort of
very compelling picture and i think
right now we actually just don't have
enough information about this new b1617
variant
right and how difficult is it to track
because the kent variant that was
detectable by an s
gene dropout which you can pick up
through a standard pcr
test is the indian variant one that you
would need more advanced
methods to detect and is that why was
such a question mark about its
prevalence
that's exactly right so the kent variant
had a kind of coincidental
useful property in that one of its
mutations made it as you said trackable
by
a certain signal in the pcr test that we
use very widely
and that means we could see it in kind
of real time and also
in very large numbers of tests conducted
in the uk
the b1617 variant in india doesn't have
that property
one needs to read the complete genome of
the virus in every sample to be certain
whether it's present or not and at the
moment there's a growing but relatively
small amount of genome sequencing in
india so they've had
over four million cases in this current
wave
but only published about a thousand
sequences it's a tiny proportion
and it can be very difficult to know if
that proportion that have been sequenced
are representative
of the huge number of cases that are
being transmitted
and if they aren't then that means you
can't sort of make the leap that the
exact proportion
we see in the sequence data represents
how much is out there in the country as
a whole
all right now there's been a lot said
about how this is a double mutant strain
which sounds
pretty terrifying is it yeah i think
that's really overblown
um so all of these variants of concern
that we've been looking at the kent one
the the b1351 from south africa the one
that was first seen in brazil
these all have a number of mutations so
the virus has about 30
000 letters in its genome and usually
these variants that seem concerning have
10 or 20 mutations or differences
from the ancestral version the same is
true of
of the indian variant it has i forgot
about a dozen i think
two of which are potentially concerning
and those two are why someone coined it
the double mutant
one of them was previously seen in a
variant in california
i'd actually say those two mutations
that have grabbed headlines are not in
the
top tier of biologically scariest
mutations
compared for example to some of the ones
in the kent or south african variants
and for that reason i think we don't
know whether it's very difficult to
predict this virus and whether there
might be some aspect of its biology we
don't understand
but i don't think there's any need to
panic right now i don't think there's
any clear evidence
for example that these mutations would
make vaccines less effective against
this variant
how many mutations are there of covert
that we know or how many can we estimate
but there are so far
so there are many tens of thousands of
mutations because these things happen
sort of all the time in the virus in all
the transmissions that are happening
around the world
so tens of thousands of mutations and
but why should it be that when we see
one from kent one from south africa one
from mexico
that we talk as if the very mutation is
reason to worry and there's something
going on if there are tens of thousands
of mutations anyway
well i think that's a good point and and
um almost all of the mutations we see
do basically nothing to the virus's
biological properties and are not
interesting except
they can be used as a kind of bar code
to track the virus
the reason that we do get somewhat
excited about
the indian variant and the kent one and
so forth is that some of those mutations
have properties that make them perhaps
more worrying so for example
when they appear in the spike protein of
the virus that's the
kind of most important bit the virus
uses to bind to human cells
that is likely more concerning
more recently there have been a number
of laboratory experiments where specific
mutations
have been tested in viruses and dishes
to show that for example they can bind
more tightly to human cells and infect
better or that possibly they can
evade certain antibodies that our immune
systems produce so i think
we're getting better at having these
predictors of which mutations are a bit
worrying
and which ones are probably benign and
meanwhile we can keep account of them
can't we i mean the the variant's been
here for several months now since
february and right now
i think there's only something like 100
cases being detected so can we deter
can we infer from that that the indian
variant whether it's more dangerous or
not
is certainly not growing in the way that
the kent variant has pretty much taken
over the coveted story
in continental europe i think that's
likely the case
it's difficult to make a direct
comparison because of course in the last
few months the country's been under a
tight lockdown and that seems to be
driving down the numbers of all variants
of the virus which is very good news
um but one thing that's becoming clear
is that of the 100 or so observations so
far
almost all of them i think are either
from people who recently traveled from
india or their contacts of
of those travelers and that means that
in some sense the
early warning system is working we're
detecting that now we know there's a lot
of cases in india
we know a lot of people test positive
when they travel from there
and a reasonable fraction of them have
this b1617 but
it doesn't seem yet to be transmitting
onward in the community generally and i
think that's a very
good sign so far and obviously something
we have to watch very carefully going
forward
now i imagine well can you ever see a
time where
we would not be worried about a covid's
mutation
it's argued that as the as the virus
enters its final years we can anything
expect more more dangerous
um mutations as it seeks to evolve and
dodge the vaccines
but i'm thinking that right now we're
closing our borders
if we're taking very strong quarantine
regulations because we're worried about
a potential
mutation for the virus of where there
are tens of thousands of mutations
i can't quite see the process where this
ends and where we would not
be worried from what you're saying kobud
will keep mutating for the rest of his
life on this planet and there is
i can't quite see what point we start
stop worrying
about mutations well i think um
in some sense that's right we're
entering a kind of new phase of the
pandemic where
there are variants around the world and
we watch carefully and
and are most interested in knowing if
any of those variants are
less well neutralized by vaccines and
you know i think we don't know yet and
that's the
reason for concern that being said i
think it really emphasizes
a fundamental point that a number of
people from the who and others have made
which is
nowhere in the world is really safe
until everywhere is safe
it is not sensible to think that if the
uk successfully finishes vaccinating its
entire population
but there are hundreds of thousands of
cases per day in india
that the pandemic is somehow over for us
travel restrictions are one way to try
to
limit that that sort of import and
onward transmission
in that situation obviously australia
and new zealand for example have been
doing that for months already
but i don't think anybody wants to live
in a world where we permanently have
such strict travel restrictions
and i think that's why efforts to more
equitably distribute vaccines around the
whole world are so very important
i'm sure but this is what a lot of
people can't quite understand
if we end up with herd immunity in this
country the government thinks we're
going to get there
by october some and think we'll get
there earlier
but say if we hit there at one point
isn't the whole purpose there
that any variant of of covis any one of
the tens of thousands that we've spoken
about
ought not to trouble us simply because
it wouldn't be able to spread because it
wouldn't
find enough people to spread to i can't
quite work out why
if we do hit herd immunity which is the
government's strategy perhaps an
undeclared strategy but if we hit herd
immunity through vaccination
why would we then be worried about
people bringing covert into britain
if we're not aware of any mutant strain
which dodges the vaccine or causes
re-infection
well exactly that that is the x-factor
which is there are no variants
yet proven to dodge vaccines or cause
reinfection but there are some
for which there is reasonable concern or
worry that they might be better able to
um reinfect individuals who've been
vaccinated and that's the
so that's i think hopefully not a very
likely outcome that there will be
fundamentally
variants that will be able to evade the
vaccines at a very substantial level
but obviously the consequence of that is
so enormous that i think
governments are taking precautionary
steps to say we get to hurt immunity
we try to gather as much data as
possible to understand if these
new variants pose a real threat to that
herd immunity or if they
there is for example a possibility that
some of these variants might
um create some infections but they'll be
relatively mild
possibly unlikely to transmit on
onwardly and possible and very unlikely
to become severe disease or death and
that might be something that
society can learn to live with so i
think that's the
question is which of those possible
scenarios is likely to play out
an unlikely but very bad one where we'd
have another wave of a new variant of
the virus
a perhaps also unlikely but very rosy
one where the vaccines work perfectly
against every variant of the virus
or something in between where we have to
sort of adjust our lifestyle
in response to exactly whether there are
other variants and how much they might
not be as
as neutralized by the vaccines at what
points can we
declare that we're no longer worried for
example about the south african variant
that was found in some
laboratory tests science and some real
world tests to be
le and better at getting through the
astra vaccine for example
and then there's some studies in israel
recently looking at people who had been
infected despite having been vaccinated
and they found
far greater prevalence of south africa
south africa variant than they had
thought but still if you look at south
africa itself their cases are down
something like 98
from the peak so i'm not quite sure at
what stage we think
okay we've seen a couple of concerning
studies but realistically it's not that
much
of a threat it's difficult to declare
with any confidence
that whatever new variant it is be
indian south african brazilian
is no longer a threat you're going to
get concerning studies that are always
going to are they not
give us pause for concern i just can't
quite see when this cycle would end
well i think we will get more
informative data the
one of the studies that you alluded to
in israel is informative i think in that
they did see
a larger proportion of um
of infections after double-dose
vaccination of the south african variant
but the total number if i remember
rightly was something like eight yeah so
it's
perhaps this is this is where i was
going but it can perhaps get through a
bit better
but it's not as if israel is
experiencing
a um a wave right now of south africa
very
getting through their vaccines i think
that's tick a a good
point of confidence i think you'll see
again perhaps some data from
the eastern part of france and
luxembourg and europe have a reasonable
amount of b1351 the south african
variant
they're also vaccinating quite quickly
so we should get data there
and we'll also be looking very carefully
in the uk here
um we have very low levels of of the
south african variant in the community
um and the government is trying hard to
get that to zero with things like the
surge testing in south london we saw a
week or so ago
but i think what we'll do in the next
month or so as
restrictions are lifted we sequence a
very large fraction more than half now
of all the new
positive cases in the countries we know
how many cases of these variants there
are
and we'll be able to ask questions like
are we seeing more cases of south africa
now that we're getting close to herd
immunity
are they enriched in the vaccines
compared to other lineages of the virus
and i think you're right that hopefully
there will be
a kind of drum beat of reassuring
stories that will mean
we don't have to be quite as petrified
of these variants
as we perhaps have been of course we're
talking about vaccines all the time but
a variant which causes reinfection is as
much of a risk now
it's uh more than a year since the virus
kicked off
how many countries have there been where
re-infections have been
um a feature of the pandemic i was
trying to have a look at
reinfection numbers and they're pretty
hard to find i think there's a dutch
company which tries to list them and
it's got fewer than 150 documented
reinfections worldwide that struck me as
a
very low number for a virus where
there'd been tens of millions of
infections so i don't know if your
institute has been looking at this in
any greater detail
so so we haven't in particular but we
have been contributing data to it to i
think an important effort to look at
this it turns out to be
just very hard to prove reinfection um
sometimes people for example shed virus
for
months after they've been infected at a
very low level and it can look like
another infection but really it's just
some kind of unusual tale of their first
one so
there have been studies set up to try to
find these things uh there's one called
siren in the uk which is a study of
healthcare workers where you can imagine
is a good place to look because one it's
much easier to keep careful records and
do things like
sequence the genome of every infection
to know conclusively this is a different
variant than the person got
you know back in october of last year or
whatever and the other thing is of
course healthcare workers are
exposed more often to the virus than
most of us are so there are
efforts to document these numbers it's
still as you say these
these clear-cut cases are are small
numbers i suspect there are more
uh in the community there's an
interesting piece of stuff you can
say a bit about what this siren study
has found if you say but that is
britain's number one reinfection study
right now is siren
what's a siren found about reinfection
levels how many reinfections has it
found
um well i think what it's found is
that previous infection offers as we
would expect
very substantial i think it's something
like 85 reduced risk of getting infected
again
and i don't think they found as yet any
association between
secondary infection and um which variant
is uh you're exposed to the second time
i
suspect that's going to take a bit more
time because the
the sort of types of variants that one
has been exposed to in the uk has been
shifting over the period in which the
study's been running so
you know back last fall it was one
particular mix uh that swept through
being ken to the point where today
99.9 of new infections are the kent
variant so it's kind of
quite um difficult to tell them apart
i think there's also some interesting
data from the
ons office for national statistics and
oxford university study which looks at
the general population survey every week
and one thing they've found is pretty
consistently
there's a way the pcr test measures
approximately how much virus is in the
sample that you
take and that second infections tend to
have less virus than first infections
and i think that
kind of makes sense so that even
individuals who do get a second
infection
probably get a more mild infection and
they also might be less aware that they
even are infected the second time around
if they don't have strong symptoms
and that might also be a factor for why
so far it's been very hard to pin down
numbers of re-infections in the
community because
the second time around it might be less
likely that you notice
right and and it's funny when you pick
up the papers abroad
people talk about the british variant as
if it's which obviously is a major
problem for them but
i'm wondering what do you think the
chances are that the british variant
actually
started in britain we do more genome
sequencing than any other country in the
world i think
and it's fair to say isn't it simply
more likely that we found it first but
it probably started somewhere else
well i think uh that was certainly a
possibility when we first observed it
for exactly the reason you say we had a
very
powerful microscope to look at these
things and so when we found it it
was hard to tell the difference between
whether it had originated in britain or
somewhere else i i'm increasingly
i'm not sure but increasingly confident
it probably did originate in the uk
and the reason for that is um it seems
to transmit so quickly
that if it had risen somewhere else some
substantial amount of time before it in
the uk there would have been a very bad
wave there
and in the wake of the discovery of the
british and south african and other
variants
many many countries are now doing
sequencing and we haven't yet seen a
country turn up
where we can look back and say aha they
probably had a very bad wave that was
caused by this instead we usually see it
kind of
starting in other countries on a lag of
months
from when it began in the southeast of
england so again
no way to be totally certain but i think
it is
um reasonably likely that it began in
either
the southeast somewhere in kent or
possibly in the east of london which is
where we saw the very earliest sequences
in the uk
okay but so far i imagine no virus has
ever been scrutinized with as much
expertise as the coronavirus has
we're not seeing any significant number
of re-infections they seem to be
absolutely tiny and we're not seeing any
of the tens of thousands of variants of
dodge the vaccine
might it be fair to say that that's two
pieces of reasonably good news
i think it probably is i mean i think we
can't be too certain yet
that none of these variants are are
going to be
less well neutralized by the vaccines um
you know i don't think we have seen
i think one way to put it would be we
have certainly not yet seen a
really bad piece of news about a
particular variant and vaccine efficacy
in real world data
and as you kind of said before the
longer that time goes by
and there are variants out there in
countries where there's a lot of
vaccines
the more and more that kind of lack of
bad news becomes good news
dr jeffrey barrett thanks very much for
joining us on spectator tv
now what follows plague war well that's
what james forsyth
says in this political column for the
magazine this week he joins me now
james you're referring to the build-up
of troops in ukraine 120
000 russian troops on the border
is this real or just for sure i think
the world
international world looks particularly
fragile at the moment you have
uh china probing taiwan's air defenses
uh
iran promising to step up its enrichment
of uranium to a level is very close to
that will be required for a nuclear bomb
and as you say a hundred and twenty
thousand
russian troops sitting on the on the
border with ukraine now
i think vladimir putin intends to use
this force on the border with ukraine
as a chip um i'm not saying he intends
to actively invade ukraine
but i think he intends to extract
something for
um de-escalating those those border
pressures
i think it is no coincidence that this
is happening at a time
when putin is under not a huge but some
domestic pressure because of the
economic situation in russia and the uh
alexey navalny protests
right and your point about this
following the pandemic i mean do you
think there might be a part of putin
thinking well
the west is recovering from this trauma
i therefore might get away with more
than i might have done i had this
um had i been up to my high jinks a
couple of years ago
yeah i also think that the west now
faces to two simultaneous challenges
uh to the world order from russia and
china and uh i mean i think i mean
british foreign policy sources are
dismissive of the idea that russia and
china are coordinating their
actions but they undoubtedly benefit
from the from
the the ways in which the west is
distracted by the other for example i
think it's
kind of close to a racing certainty that
if uh
china did attempt to seize taiwan that
that russia would would take the
opportunity to cause trouble in its own
neighborhood to march into eastern
ukraine for instance
and i think that is one of the one of
the things that blackmail pc is doing
i think he is also probing to assess
uh western resolve i think it's i think
i think he would have noted for example
that
uh czechoslovakia has made you know
prague has made an appeal
sorry for czech republic so prague has
made an appeal for other countries to
follow its lead eu lead
uh other eu countries whether it's
needed in expelling uh russian diplomats
and you know there hasn't been a
coordinated joint expulsion
following the checks blaming the
russians for an explosion that killed
several track people in 2014 and so i
think that what putin is doing is
assessing how serious the west is how
prepared it is to stand up to him
i'm joined now by carl biltz the former
foreign minister and prime minister of
sweden
and the very long a long-standing
watcher of the situation in that part of
the world
so um car belt how delicate is the
situation in ukraine right now if you
look at the sheer number of trips things
look
quite sensitive but i'm not sure if
that's a decoy
well we simply don't know i mean what we
do know
is that there's been a very significant
build-up of military forces on crimea
for some exercises
but also around the borders of ukraine
and the most significant military
buildup since uh
the acute face of the crisis in 2014 and
2015.
these are expensive uh things i mean you
don't do them for fun they are there for
a purpose for some sort of
some sort of thing and and that of
course creates a certain amount of
nervousness
i imagine also that patient will be
testing europe's response now we saw
that after the
incident in salisbury and britain
succeeded in getting europe to give a
combined response
in when we expelled russian diplomats
and but this time around a few days ago
when czech republic and expelled
diplomats
there was not a concerted european
response do you think that european
unity
is beginning to fracture no i don't
think so
i think what has been happening in the
sort of this russia ukraine case
now is that the fact that it has
attracted so much attention and we had x
numbers of telephone calls
to putin in the kremlin and to president
selenski in
in in kiev offering support i think that
has had a
deterrent effect it has been made clear
to president putin that where he to go
further crossing the obvious red lines
that would have significant consequences
um
so i think as a matter of fact the
political action of the political
signaling
that we've seen during the last few
weeks have probably
we have to reserve judgment has prob
have probably been successful
right but we've seen recently for
example when joe biden came in
he was keen that germany canceled the
nordstrom 2 projects that would link
expand the pipeline to russia the reason
for that is that poland and indeed the
european parliament were begging germany
not to go ahead with this because this
would allow peach in great
far greater latitude to get up to more
maneuvers in ukraine
germany is still pressing a heads
and that must be a little bit of a
problem
that is a problem primarily i think it's
a problem for the german american
relationship
primarily i mean there's a as
as you're aware of there's significant
opposition in germany also to this
particular pipeline
that being said there is a significant
opposition in
germany to the americans doing sanctions
against an ally
the germans are saying you can have
different views on this one but that is
for us to decide not for you to decide
and try to impose your will so it is it
is it is uh creating tensions i i think
the
the significance of the issue is
somewhat overblown uh but
uh clearly it's uh it's unfortunate
okay um vladimir putin gave his annual
address to the nation a few days ago and
in it
he spoke about russia as being a tiger
surrounded by
hyenas do you think that's how he
regards europe now
as hyenas to his tiger i think he
creates uh
uh yeah i think he has that particular i
mean my interpretation was as a matter
of fact that sort of the tiger was more
the united states perhaps than the other
hyenas but but anyhow
that's obviously the way he he sees it
but otherwise i was surprised by his
speech because it was so
bland as a matter of fact difficult to
see that he hadn't
thought of the possibility of saying
something of
a relationship with ukraine but there
was absolutely nothing in it
and that sort of invites a lot of
questions
one of the theories that james forsyth
that advanced him as spectator
is that putin might be doing the
build-up in ukraine
in order to de-escalate later and take
some credit for it
for example we now get alexander navalny
who's very ill
in a russian m prison if something were
to happen to him
then there would be big reaction
certainly from the west
but james is saying in that case putin
might say okay i'm going to de-escalate
ukraine
and then somehow use that to assuage
what would otherwise be a nasty far
harsher reaction
to vinnivalene situation i doubt there's
any link between the two i think the
these are two different developments uh
you can perhaps trace them back to the
same common denominator that is that
sort of the nervousness in russia
what's going to happen in september with
the duke elections and the
internal instability tendencies that
there are in the inside the regime
itself
but but otherwise i failed to see any
connection with the between the navalny
crisis and the
and the ukraine crisis we'll see if they
de-escalate i mean there's a
statement coming out of the russian
defense ministry today that they are
sort of starting to withdraw forces well
they've done that from syria or
announced that from syria i don't know
how many times
so we'll have um we just have to wait
and see what happens
how much of this do you think putin is
simply testing new leadership
in the world we've got joe biden we've
got new
new leadership in the european union do
you think he's just prodding to see how
people react
i think it's primarily prodding the the
ukraine leadership i i i think he's
irritated with ukraine leadership
they have not from his point of view
been delivering the concessions that he
had been hoping for
and they have also lately taken some
rather firm actions against his uh
his close political allies in in in in
ukraine i think that has irritated the
the kremlin quite substantially and i
think the primary signaling here is uh
towards kiev to a certain extent perhaps
against brussels and then and washington
or they think rather that he believes
that
those those relationships are so rock
bottom at the moment
that it doesn't make much of a
difference anyhow what it does
and what kind of signal do you think
mkev is getting from
the from europe in general because right
now if you see
um the miracle government pressing ahead
of nordstrom 2
then you do wonder just um how important
ukraine's protection that ukraine's um
part as part part of the europeans near
abroad really is
it might seem as if europe isn't really
much of a position to do anything
coherent at all because
putin's successfully playing one country
off against another
well i think it's been a very unified
response there has been
telephone calls from sort of from
chancellor merkel from president macron
for presidency of finland
and and they've all been i understand uh
very clear that if it crosses the red
lines that would be significant uh
significant steps taken by by the
european union
right can we define significant steps
here i mean anybody can make phone calls
what kind of significant steps could we
plausibly see the european union take
no i i think that if if there were to be
sort of open aggression i mean that's
the worst case analysis
first that would be very close
coordination between brussels and and
london i would assume as well and the
measures that can be taking those would
be financial sanctions i mean the
americans took some
some action the other day they were
extremely mild and
and i think one of the reasons the
american sanctions the other day were so
mild was that they send
they want to send the message well we
can do these things
and and we have a lot of room left in
in terms of that and if if if that is
done coordinated across the atlantic it
can have a very significant effect on
the
russian economy and they know that but
putin annexed crimea a few years ago
he's got away with that
he's been effectively wearing waging war
in eastern ukraine for years now with
something like
14 000 dead he's also got away with that
so you can understand why he might think
he might be able to get away with a
little bit more
before there's any serious response from
nato or from the eu or anybody in the
west
but i think the sanctions that have been
decided already there's a lot of
discussion always have they worked or
have they not worked
um they have not worked in terms of
having him roll back and sort of give
back crimea and give back to the bus he
hasn't done that
but it hasn't gone any further and and i
think that's a recognition of the fact
that this
these tankers have had an effect they
have an effect on
sections i mean they're not total trade
sanctions by no means
but they have uh they have a financial
effect on access to financial markets
they have an effect to
russia's ability to access certain key
high technologies that they need also
for their energy and other related
developments
so i think there's a there's an
awareness of the fact that
sanctions aren't killing russia but
they're creating
quite a lot of problems right but i mean
domestically vladimir putin seems to be
quite
quite solid right now the protests about
navalny's treatment do seem to be
speaking for a minority of russians
there was one poll showing a third of
russians
think that he wasn't poisoned at all but
further 20 percent
think that navalny was um the victim of
some kind of western plot
so it seems that um domestically
putin's pretty stable well i wouldn't
say president
but but i recently stayed but i what
what what do you see a significant
divide in russia that is opening up
between what i call the television
generation
i mean the elder generation that sort of
are dependent upon what is said on
television
and of course what he said on television
i mean we all fairly aware of
what he said on television in russia but
then you have the january the jungle
generation that's the internet
generation they don't watch television
um they access
information through youtube which is a
and and this also telegram and
and related cables uh channels in
in in russia so you see the internet
generation
being sort of increasingly sort of
critical
while the television generation which is
still bigger
still sort of enthusiasts more
reluctantly
supporting putin well carl belts thank
you for joining us
on our youtube television today that's
it from the week in 60 minutes today i'd
like to thank
charles stanley our sponsor that one of
the oldest companies on the london stock
exchange
if you've got any comments we'd always
love to hear them please email spectator
tv
at spectator dot co dot uk thanks for
watching and thanks to our producers
cindy yu and max jeffrey
[Music]
you